It's just on their tolerance of destiny and and his current actions
positions, right? And somehow
it's like Mir Quimman laughing at this loser that's that's making
his friends run away. It's not him, you know, totally willfully
negligently messaging a minor minor, sorry, minor. It's not him
trying to traffic that minor across multiple states to to get
her to come see him for. It's not about uh doxing a bunch of
people. It's not about, you know, I think it could be reasonably
assumed he's connected to the docses of some of the people that
were fighting with him a couple weeks ago, right? Like there's
it's not none of these actions.
It's just it's just like uh it's the snark community. Okay.
All right. Pixie Pixie docks. And then we I don't know. I don't
know what we're going to do here. I need some music. I need better
music than this. I need some What do I need? I don't know what
music I need. This is too much. Thought you were going to do
a voice. Shut up. Plaintiff Jane Doe's motion. This is the new
motion from Pixie today. All right. Plaintiff Jane Doe's motion
for order to show cause why defendant should not be held in contempt
and request for sanctions and injunctive relief. So basically,
hey, we think you should be held in contempt. Go ahead and tell
me why not. All right. Tell me why not. Comes now plaintiff Jane
Doe buy and through under signed counsel and hereby moves for
an order requiring defendant to show cause why he should not
be held in civil contempt for willfully violating this court's
order sealing the transcript of the June 3rd 2025 preliminary
injunction hearing and respectfully states as follows. Introduction
plaintiff respectfully moves for an order requiring defendant
to show cause why he should not be held in civil contempt for
willfully violating this court's order sealing the transcript
of the June 3rd 2025 preliminary injunction hearing order ECF91.
Despite the court's clear directive that the transcript remains
sealed due to the highly sensitive and explicit nature of the
testimony, defendant has publicly read from and discussed the
sealed transcript during a live broadcast on a streaming channel.
He also showed the sealed transcript to the individual he was
interviewing so she could read it. Now, this is technically on
food shop's streaming channel, but okay. Defendants's willfully
or willful conduct brazenly undermines the authority of the court,
violates plaintiff's privacy rights, and causes irreparable harm.
Defendants's bad faith violation of this court order should be
sanctioned. Relevant background. On June 3rd, 2025, Magistrate
Judge Torres presided over a preliminary injunction hearing in
this matter. Due to the nature of the testimony, which involved
detailed and explicit descriptions central to the plaintiff's
claim of non-consensual disclosure of intimate images as well
as mental health testimony, plaintiff moved to seal the transcript
ECF88.
On June 6th, 2025, the magister judge granted the motion and
directed the clerk of the court to maintain the transcript at
DE90 as fully sealed pending further order of the court. Order
ECF91. Emphasis applied. Despite the plaintiff's motion to seal
had despite that plaintiff's motion to seal had already been
granted, and without providing any valid reason to unseal the
transcript, defendant Banal filed an opposition ECF 101. Plaintiff's
reply demonstrated the frivolity of defendants's opposition ECF
106. Plaintiff's reply also highlighted defendants declared intent
and eagerness to read the transcript out loud to his million
plus followers on his streaming platform. Funnily enough, the
doc was actually filed this way. Wait, what do you mean actually
filed this way? In what way? On August 12th, 2025, in willful
violation of the court's order, defendant discussed the sealed
hearing and read aloud portions of the sealed transcript during
a live broadcast
on his streaming channel. He then posted the video on YouTube.
The following is the relevant portion from the defendant's live
stream transcript. Wait, is this actually from his Wait, this
is actually his video. Hold on. >> It was really brutal.
Um, >> wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Are we mixing?
Are we mixing? What? What are we We're mixing some stuff here.
This is one. Oh, this was live streamed on June 3rd. Posted on
June 4th. Sure, sure, sure. On August 12th is what we're looking
for at the bottom here. No. Well, maybe not. He then posted the
video on YouTube. This is the This the following is the relevant
portion of the defendant's live stream transcript. Oh my god,
bro. Dude, that transcript is when I get to read that, there's
no that it's going to be sealed forever. I'm just recalling I'm
just recalling some things from my very, very good memory. Okay,
I'm recalling from my very, very good memory. Unfortunately for
Destiny, okay, unfortunately for Destiny,
he actually explicitly said he'd ordered the transcript, right?
He said so explicitly
on his stream. Like, I have ordered it. It should be here in
a day or two and then I can read from it. Right? So when he says
it's just his very very good memory, I'm sure there's some record
of him actually ordering it. The italicized portion above is
Benell reading verbatim from the sealed hearing transcript. See
ECF90, page 40, lines 3 to 22. Banel makes a farcical pretense
of recalling the testimony from his memory by interjecting. Oh,
no way. He didn't just summarize it. He actually read it verbatim.
Oh, that's that's not good. He thinks the judge is going to fall
for this [__] bro. There's no way he just pulled
the transcript out and started reading it. I'm just recalling
some things from a very very good memory or I think my lawyer
said or I think she said something like but a comparison of the
hearing transcript with what Benell said reveals it is verbatim
>> as referenced. >> Thus despite his admitted awareness
that the transcript is sealed and that he should not be disclosing
the testimony. He proceeds to read it out loud sorry aloud in
a flagrant mockery of the court's order. Furthermore, right after
reading the above portion of the transcript out loud, Banell
also showed the sealed transcript to the streamer he was interviewing
on his liveream so that she could read it for herself. Um, wait,
okay, you know, don't show this to the live stream viewers. This
is what I'm talking about. Do you understand?
Plaintiff was made aware of the above content on defendants's
liveream/YouTube video on Friday, August 15th, 2025. The underside
council immediately commenced reviewing the
the matter and determined the extent of the violation. On Monday
morning, August 18th, 2025, plaintiff became aware that sometime
on August 16th or 17th, Defendant edited the YouTube video of
his live stream in order to So, I see. So, this is all referring
to food shops, by the way. Food shops edited the live stream
to cut that part out, right? That's No, no, no, no, no. I'm I'm
going to be EP no matter what. It's unfortunately a fact of life.
I can I can yawn. It happens. But yeah, dude, I don't think this
becomes okay just because you do it on somebody else's video
or somebody else's channel, right? I don't think this is like
somehow okay because he doesn't own the ch the channel. Seems
like quite bad no matter what. However, this belated effort does
not in any way cure the violation given that the live stream
video has already amassed 4,000 views and the harm to plaintiff
and the authority of this court has already occurred. Moreover,
an excerpt of the offending portion of the video was posted on
Kiwi Farms and has probably been reposted on multiple other social
media sites. Pursuant to local rule 71A2
on Monday, August 8 18th at 10 a.m., the undersigned council
reached out to council for the defendant via email in an attempt
to resolve the serious issue. Council for defendant, Mr. Brenler,
did not respond until the morning of the 19th, claiming that
we looked into the matter and could find no evidence of wrongdoing
by Mr. Bennell. The undersigned council responded by providing
the same evidence submitted in the instant motion. This morning,
Mr. Breler responded blindly, asserting that his client did not
violate the court's order. The magistrate judges judge's paperless
order docket number uh 91 merely directs the clerk to seal a
transcript of the June 3r 2025 hearing pending a further order
the court. Mr. Bennell never filed the trans or filed the transcript
or any portions thereof on the public docket nor did he publish
a copy of the transcript online or elsewhere. Mr. Benell has
a first amendment right to discuss the lawsuit and your cl that
your client has filed against him. There are also no restrictions
on Mr. Benell's right to discuss what happened at the June 3rd
hearing as will be detailed below. Mr. Breler's self-s serving
interpretation of the court sealing order is unsupported by federal
legal principles and shows a lack of respect for the authority
of the court. The clear and convincing evidence from the cited
video link demonstrates the defendant willfully, intentionally,
and in bad faith violated the letter in spirit of the court's
order and he should be held accountable and deterred from further
violations. Bretter must hate Destiny at this point. You're wrong.
No, you're wrong. Stalin sloth. Bretter loves Destiny. Why wouldn't
Bretler love Destiny? Rentler's literally buying Lambo after
Lambo for this guy being a
Yes, bro. Yeah, it's uh Listen, Destiny used to have to hook
up, okay? He He used to have to try to pay miners for videos
on Twitter to get this kind of pay action, okay? That's what
he used to do. Now he just found Andrew Breler. Andrew Brettler
is one of the biggest He is the He's the kingpin of FindDom,
okay? And Destiny's paying up over and over and over again. It's
wild. The legal standard for finding contempt of the court. The
court has inherent power to enforce compliance with its lawful
orders through civil contempt. Shilatani v. United States. This
docket. Civil contempt occurs when a party disobys a specific
specific and definite court order by failing to take all reasonable
all reasonable steps within that party's power to comply with
the order. Gladen versus Proctor and Gamble uh distributed
distributors LLC. district courts have wide latitude to determine
if there has been contemptuous defiance of its order. Furthermore,
courts have inherent power to impose sanctions for failure to
comply with the court order. And this is some precedent for it.
To exercise its inherent power, a court must find that the party
acted in bad faith. At 49, one aspect of a court's inherent power
is the ability to assess attorney's fees and costs against the
client or his attorney or both when either has acted in bad faith
fixiously, wantingly, or for oppressive reasons. McDonald Cooper's
another
affirming sanctions against council for violating protective
order by disclosing a deposition transcript marked as confidential
to unauthorized persons citing Burn Vzat uh quotation marks committed
see also this case finding that a defendant acted in bad faith
by disregarding orders and imposing the sanction of striking
defendants pleadings and entering defaults. Andrew see Kyoko
uh Andrew Brettler probably really respects Destiny's debate
chops. JK he's laughing his ass off all the way to the bank dude.
Breler. Yeah, Bretler does not care. Okay, he this guy doesn't
give a if Destiny's going to be He's going to help Destiny be
the most destructive he wants to be. That's what Andrew Bettler
paid gets paid the big bucks for. Okay, Andrew Breler gets paid
the big bucks. I would even be shocked if Destiny can like if
he does these things that it's actually quite difficult to reprimand
him effectively, right? That's what he's paying Andrew Breler
for. Destiny is paying Andrew Brettler so Andrew Breler can say,
"Okay, I know that this transcript is sealed. I know you want
to talk about it. Here's how you have to phrase it to try to
skirt getting actually sanctioned for it. Okay, here's how you
got to do it precisely. Here's the here's the way to do it, right?
I'm telling you, this is Andy B coaching him on how to do it.
It's very possible Destiny gets away with this. Okay, cuz that's
what Andy B gets paid the big bucks to do, to tell you how to
uh, you know, how to shame and attack your victims in the best
way possible. That's Andy. That's why Andy B gets paid the big
bucks. All right. The other day, Destiny has said he already
paid 300k at this point. Awesome. We love to see it. There's
another precedent that says uh it shows that there's a finding
or there's a finding of the court that defendants and their council
acted in bad faith and willfully violated court orders, entering
default judgement and an award of attorney fees and costs. Oh,
this is just from what we had above. Okay. Defendant acted in
bad faith by willfully violating the court's sealing order and
should be held in contempt. The court's order sealing the transcript
was clear and unambiguous. Defendant Banell's reading of the
transcript in his live stream to all of his followers and showing
the transcript to his fellow streamer unequivocally demonstrates
bad faith defiance of the order. Bad faith is also evidenced
by Benell's explicit acknowledgement of the sealing order right
before he discusses the testimony and reads aloud from the transcript.
It's also evidenced by his farscal comments that he purportedly
has a very very good memory enabling him to recite recite verbatim
a full 5 minutes of testimony. Banell has or Benell had no legitimate
reason for reading the transcript out loud. Rather, the only
plausible reason for disclosing the testimony in his is uh sorry
is his interest in continuing to exploit those proceedings for
personal profit and performative harassment, embarrassment, and
oppression of the plaintiff. Banell has made a deliberate and
blanket mockery of the court's authority and accordingly should
be found in contempt and sanctioned. Pretty sure he said 400k
when talking to food slops. Uh I don't believe him, right? I
actually don't believe him. I don't think it's been that much.
I don't think he'll post like receipts showing that, right? I
don't think he could produce receipts saying that. He said 300k
so far. Okay, that's much better. I still I still kind of doubt
he could produce receipts of that. Okay, mostly because so many
people would get off to that. Okay, I'm sorry. You show me Desty's
$300,000 legal bill to Andrew Breler. There's a lot of people
who would enjoy to see that. Okay, I don't think it could be
produced. Defendant's purported defense of his conduct has no
basis in law or fact. By the way, I wouldn't have laughed at
that so much. All right. Before his whole like doxing and and
death threat spree. All right. I wouldn't have laughed at it
quite as hard cuz I I would have felt like that was petty and
and kind of But now it's like, "Yeah, [__] this guy.
This guy, okay, he deserves no charity. He just doesn't." Uh
defendants defendants's purported defense of his conduct has
no basis in law or fact. As set forth above, council for defendant
has the temerity to contend that defendant did not violate the
sealing order because he never filed the transcript or any portions
thereof on the public docket, nor did he publish a copy of the
transcript online or elsewhere. This contention is belied by
the clear and unambiguous facts and is completely unsupported
by any legal precedent. There can be no question that by reading
the transcript out loud to his thousands of followers and or
by showing it to his fellow streamer, Benell did in fact publish
the transcript. A sealing order is not a mere administrative
measure to keep the PDF off the docket. It is a directive of
the court that the substance of the sealed document is to not
be publicly disseminated. To conrue the seal as covering only
the physical transcript while permitting public reading of the
display or or display of its content renders the that order,
sorry, the order meaningless and an exercise in futility. Now,
this is kind of true, but I would wonder if it was narrowly tailored,
if this uh protective order was narrowly tailored and was about
or mental health issues, then is the portion of the transcript
he's reading actually about those issues? Like, I'm trying to
think of how Breler would have told Destiny to talk about this
in the way he wanted to, right? He might have said, "Well, here's
how this is tailored, and if you if you stay outside of the tailored
topics and you just say you're reading from memory, I think you'll
be okay." Right? I I think that's probably in my head what was
said to him. Okay. Council for defendant also contends that Benell
has a first amendment right to discuss the lawsuit. There are
no restrict also no restrictions on Mr. Benell's right to discuss
what happened at the June 3rd hearing. Defendants reliance on
the first amendment is misplaced. While parties may generally
speak about their litigation, the first amendment does not shield
conduct that violates a valid court order. A sealing order is
strongly uh is sorry a sealing order is narrowly tailored to
protect the integrity of the judicial proceedings, the privacy
of participants and any other interests the court deemed compelling.
defendant cannot cloak his violation of that order in constitutional
rhetoric. Asserting a first amendment right to broadcast sealed
testimony does not override the court's protecting uh the integrity
of sealed proceedings.
Defendants live stream disclosure frustrates the court's directive
and renders meaningless the very purpose of sealing. I guess
if the entire transcript is sealed, you might be able to say
any part of that contributes, right? It's 100% what was said
to him, but Big D thought he could trick everyone by reading
the transcript on stream. I I don't know why he didn't just uh
I don't know why he didn't just go ahead and like summarize.
Just sum it up, bro. Just sum it up. What are we doing? Yeah,
paraphrase. Ain't no way he hasn't already got a private crew.
He's always been a sure. Oh, sorry. Sorry. It's differently.
That's a different conversation. Jesus Christ. Okay, we got to
get through this. I said I would do it. I said I would make it.
Okay. I said I would make it and we're going to do it. We're
going to make it happen. All right. Let's go.
Let's go. The dissemination of plaintiff's testimony containing
explicit details compounds the harm plaintiff has already suffered
and which serve as the basis for her claims. By disregarding
the court's order and its authority, defendant has once again
intentionally sought to inflict further emotional distress and
reputationable reputational injury upon plaintiff andor to shame
her into abandoning her claims and deter witnesses from coming
forward. The live stream video was viewed by more than 4,000
people and is being reposted on other sites. plaintiff urges
the court to order defendant to one immediately remove all video/
audio/online content that references or quotes from the sealed
transcript and two cease and desist from any further disclosure
or discussion of the sealed material in any forum. Plaintiff
also requests that the court order that the court enter an order
finding the defendant in contempt for his brazen violation of
the court's order and imposing appropriate sanctions including
a substantial monetary fine and payment to of plaintiff's reasonable
attorney's fees and costs incurred in having to bring this motion.
Clearly without appropriate sanctions, defendant will continue
to disregard the orders of the court and inflict further harm
on plaintiff. Wow. Here, defendant is not a typical litigant.
He is a professional online streamer whose income is largely
derived from publicly discussing and posting about controversial
topics, including this lawsuit. Since the outset of the case,
defendant has repeatedly posted about details of the case on
his streaming platforms, mocked and insulted plaintiff and her
legal team, and weaponized court filings for online content.
The Venet has also publicly ridiculed Plaintiff's mental health,
history, and her witnesses. This is not speculative. His pattern
of commentary is well documented and includes live streams, tweets,
and reposts designed to stir harassment by his audience. See
ECF numbers 73, 82, 84, 98, 104, 105. For this reason, the monetary
fine should be substantial in order to deter defendant from further
defiance of court orders and further mockery of these proceedings
and the authority of the court. Jesus Christ, is this guy okay?
Queen, come get your people. Quan, if you're here, come get your
people. Okay.
What? What the dude? Yeah, you got some weirdos in my chat right
now. Queen, come get your freaks. Rope them back into your community.
What the [__] going on? Conclusion: The court's or
sealing order encompasses not only the transcript document, but
also the testimony it records. Defendants's public broadcast
of that testimony by reading from and displaying the sealed transcript
was a direct violation of that order. His conduct cannot be excused
under the guise of free speech and the court should impose sanctions
to ensure its orders are complied with. Wherefore plaintiff respectfully
requests that this honorable court hold defendant in contempt
of court. Order order defendant to immediately remove all video/
audio/online content that references or quotes from the sealed
transcript. Order defendant to cease and desist from further
disclosure or discussion of the sealed material in any forum
or to anyone. Order defendant to pay plaintiff's costs and fees
incurred in connection with the disclosure of the transcript
and in bringing this motion. Impose appropriate sanctions, including
a substantial monetary fine for defendants's willful violation
of court's order, and grant any other relief the court deems
just and proper. Respectfully submitted on the 21st day of August,
2025.
Joan Schlump Peters and Carlos A. Garcia and Gustavo D
Pixie's lawyers explain why she's allowed to sue Jane Doe. I
never knew you could file anonymous lawsuits. Why is that? Uh
she's allowed to file as Jane do because it's a crime, right?
For most crimes, for most um yeah, most crimes there's there's
the option to file things um privately.
And yeah, so she's doing so. He hasn't streamed in two days that
are breaking containment.
They are. They are. Why didn't you type out what he actually
says, Queman? Don't just say NSTLK. Why don't you type out what
he was actually saying? It was the Ethan Klein's kids thing.
That that was like kind of freakish. just a talk. It's fine.
But the uh the NSDLK thing is uh kind of psychotic, bro. All
right. Uh I mean that seems reasonable, but I'm guessing that
there is some overlap of like he's allowed to speak on it, right?
The only thing that gets me is if he was actually reading it
verbatim.
That seems that seems kind of right. Like I don't know how he
gets away with that. How the [__] you get away with
reading that [__] verbatim? We're very scared of
the snark label here. Uh that's actually not true. I already
said we were snarking. We're snarking today. Any snarkers in
the chat? Starkers hit three. Starkers hit three right now. Starkers
threes in the chat. Any starkers? Any starkers? I already said
we were snarking today. Okay, we're not scared of that label.
They put a link of Destiny reading it. Okay. I thought he read
verbatim on the 12th. Am I crazy? And posted a video from YouTube
calling from my very, very good memory. Do we have this clip?
Do we have it anywhere here? Do we have the clip? Do we have
the clip? Do we have the clip? Where's the clip? Where's the
clip? Where's the clip? Okay. Where's the clip, guys? Don't have
it. Don't have it. Can't find it. Unlucky. Is this the food shops
clip? Okay, perfect. No, it's not his VOD from the 12th. This
is the food shop stream. It has to be the food shop >> Another
thing that came up was um Hold on. I'm just recalling I'm just
recalling some things from my very very good memory. Okay, I'm
recalling from my very very good memory. All right. It's funny
because like so many times when um Pixie's answering questions
in court, the judge has to like interrupt. He's like, "Wait,
who sent what?" Because the case is so weird. Like there's a
part where she's talking about like sending I guess she sent
her ex all of our videos. I never knew this but apparently she
she um did and then she says this and judge is like wait you're
saying Steven sent all of the videos of you guys hooking up to
your boyfriend and she's like no no I sent them and he's like
oh why would you do that
just like so funny
is like so confused. Um she tried to claim that it was like my
idea I guess kind of to like make videos together but it was
like clearly her idea. And then hold on. I'm trying to remember
really I'm trying to remember really really hard what was said.
Okay. I think my lawyer says something along the lines of like,
"So, does that impact your testimony at all that it was Mr. Bunnell's
idea to make the video or do you now realize that you were the
one that first raised the idea of making videos together?" And
she and I think she said something like, "What I claimed was
that he sent me Molina's stuff." And as a response to that, I
was like, "Oh, do you want me uh do you want to make stuff together?"
Because I thought him sending Molina's stuff was like, "Oh, yeah.
Like, you know, he's into recording stuff." And then I think
my lawyer repeated, "Does it refresh
>> uh hold on. This is where he's actually reading verbatim,
right? Like this is actually going to be the verbatim reading
recollection that it was your idea to actually suggest making
a video with Mr. Bonell." And then I think so she said something
like this. Okay. She goes, "I'm trying to >> So she said
something like this." Okay. She goes >> think how to phrase
this in a way that makes sense. If I'm like, "All right, I'll
use this in >> Dude, I didn't did we pick this up at the
time that like it's actually him reading it verbatim. I don't
know if we picked it up at the time. We thought he was summarizing,
but he is actually, now that you like hear it, we did. Okay.
Okay,
dude. This is this is actually like a wild thing to do. >> Analogy.
If I have like a cup of water and I drink it and I'm like, "Oh
my god." You know, >> dude, dude, dude, he's actually reading
verbatim because you get all of the little uh like all of the
filler words and right >> water is really cool. I love
water. You know, water's awesome. and you go, "Oh, hey, do you
want some water?" Because you keep, you know, you sat here talking
about water. Is it okay? I'm not sure how to phrase this. The
way >> Hold on. There is at least Joe, bro. There's at
least some self-interest in him trying to like make Pixie have
like a freak out or something, right? The other one The other
one makes like no sense. I don't know. This one like there's
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know, man. I don't know,
dude. I think I don't understand how you could get this if you
if you're reading verbatim. I don't understand how you could
how this could be fine. I don't get it. >> You know, you
sat here talking about water. Is it okay? I'm not sure how to
phrase this. The way that and then I
like is that what she sound like? >> Yeah, something like
that. Something Yeah, something
maybe similar. Something like that. Holy [__] bro.
I can't. >> Dude, if it's if it's Cook like >> Dude,
I think I think these two things put together have to be why
Dan left, right? the 17-year-old thing and then this like this
guy is just not capable of making good decisions anymore. Like
he is not capable of being a reliable business partner. Like
Dan, this is this has to be Dan just going, "You know what? Uh
I literally can't be around you anymore."
Like like Dan was ready to go to bat for this guy and this guy
has just shown exactly why we said Dan was right. Dan ain't leaving,
bro. Be real. I don't think he's leaving but Dan's No, no, no.
Dan's taking a break. Dan's taking a break until the heat's off,
right? But I think he understands right now. Dan didn't leave.
He took a break. Okay, Dan's on a break. This log right here.
No, this is about Pisco. Where's my Dan log? Give me a second.
Pull my Dan log super fast. Super quick. Super fast. Oh, bro.
Who sent this? Dude, what? There it is. Here it is. Here it is.
Putting a on indefinite hold. And he talked about going back
to rust. Okay. A is on indefinite hold. Indefinite pause. is
no anything else. No anything else. And I think it just has to
be like, dude, I was willing to stand by you, but you just keep
making horrible decisions. You just keep doing like over and
over and over and over and over again. It's not photoshopped.
It is real. It is real. It is true. This is not fake. This is
not a drill. Dan really did this. Okay, I'm not joking. Let's
just see all of the logs here. Putting AE on indefinite pause.
Anyways, I'm going back to Rust now. I'm not dying. Relax. M's
on vacation for 3 weeks. I'll see where everything is at that
at that point. I'm not stopping my Clancy fights. No tears. So,
like that's pretty obvious, dude. Oh, that podcast where they
just play Hassan clips for the whole thing. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That one. That one. Like, at what point do you have to just admit
that Yeah, Hassan won. Hassan won. This is This is actually an
admission of Hassan winning directly. Direct admission from Dan
that Hassan won. Dan quit before Connor. Listen, Dan listened
to that Connor stream and was like, "Holy, there's no way to
There's no way to sweep for this." Okay. Dan saw Connor's broom
shatter and he was like, "You know what? No thank you. We're
on an indefinite break with anything else. No thanks. Nah. Nah.
I'm out. I can't. I'm out. It can't be done. Cannot be done.
I'm out."
you watch Connor in that initial thing when Connor comes out
like, "Yeah, we knew she was 17 for a year now. Wait, you guys
are mad about her being 17? I thought we already knew she was
17. Didn't you guys all think she was 17 already? Dan's like,
"Ah, nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. No way. I'm out. I'm out. I'm out."
We need the Why are all my enemies?
I like I like the uh what just don't like the vibes I bring to
the party. My aura. Dude, some people got so mad about that comment
and it's so funny. It's just telling. Okay. You know, you know
who gets mad? You're like actually, it's just a self-fulfilling
prophecy. You say, "Everybody hates my"
and then all of the get extremely assad about it. You can't make
this up. You can't make it up. You can't make it up.
All right. All right. What else are we doing here? We finished
the trans. We finished the pixie thing. And then there was something
else. What is it? Someone tell me. Tell me. Tell me what the
new thing is. I gave you guys the three things we were doing.
It was the Auggie stream. It was the pixie docks. And it was
what was the Oh, the the snark. We're doing a little snarking.
Okay. We're actually going to join hands with the the snarkers.
Okay. Join hands with the snarkers. Check this out. Destiny doubles
down on calling for Hassan's death. >> He called for Hassan's.
>> Apparently, he called for Hassan's death. This is highlighting
that Destiny may have doubled down on calling for Hassan's death
would be sarking apparently. Now, we'll see. I hate to say it.
Okay, this is the title. The title is Destiny doubles down on
calling for son's death. This time saying it live on YouTube.
A clear toss violation, unlike when he does it in DG chat where
he gets away with it. That's also probably a toss violation.
But don't worry about it. Okay, now here's the thing. What I'm
hoping is the snarkers have not failed me. That this is actually
real, okay? Cuz I swear to God, if the snarkers did to Destiny
what Destiny and co did to Hassan, I'm going to have to call
that out, okay? I'm going to have to be fair. He better actually
do it. You better actually do it. Okay. We actually said what
did you say? I something along the lines of like like if this
is the like if this is our if this is the norm for political
commentary, you could very easily justify attacking 100%. If
the if the if it's going to be that every single Zionist, every
single everybody in Israel, even your content creator, See, here's
the thing. Okay, here's the difference between Hassan and Destiny
here. Okay, so he's he's not saying he apologized for it. Destiny
is making up a bunch of context that doesn't exist there that
he's not putting on the record. With Hassan, I can go back 30,
60, 90 seconds. I can go back 5 minutes, 10 minutes, 15 minutes,
and see exactly what Hassan was talking about. The exact context
that builds to his statement, right? With Destiny, he just goes,
"You could totally justify killing Hassan with this." Yeah, I
think you could totally justify Hassan with this. No other context.
You could very easily justify attacking or killing 100%. If the
if the if if it's going to be that every single Zionist, every
single in Israel, even your content creators uh wife or whatever
in the West Bank, like if that's the norm, that's not what he
said at all. Total creative writing, just fake, just lying. I
don't know how you can watch stuff like this and just not completely
write off how dishonest these people are. Yeah, he is just openly
lying. Like again, again, he is just lying. He's like a liar.
He's like a total totally disingenuous freak. Sounds like the
snarkers didn't fail us. Well, he is I don't know. I guess this
is doubling down. He's just lying about what Hassan said and
what Hassan was saying. He's like obviously lying. Form then
you could basically every online content creator you want. >> That's
not what you said. He didn't say every online content creator.
He said Hassan said you could justify Hassan.
That's what he said. You could justify Hassan. Oh god, we got
a bad empanada tweet. What is this?
Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Is he amongst us right now? Is he amongst us? I
like this unfortunately. But the tweet is there. Okay, hold on.
It says something along the lines of from my very very good memory.
The tweet from Bad Empanada says something along the lines of
Hold on. Can I can I remember this effectively? It It's something
like, "Will Daniel Saltman stop running a podcast with a I think
Bad Empanada tweets something along those lines." Okay, I think
it's something like that was in that rough area. Interesting
that Dan is following the directives from Interesting. Interesting.
You take a look here. Okay, this isn't the only one, dude. They
don't they don't pull any punches with these titles over on this
leftovers H3 subreddit.
Destiny, a defender deadbeat dad with a patchy beard calls Ethan
Klein spineless. Okay, hold on. Ethan and Ela scold Destiny for
helping us reframe the conversation. What is this? >> Has
nothing to do with what Hassan did to me. I don't know anything
about what Destiny did. This is not a three-way situation. know
anything about this. Apparently, it's Destiny in response to
Hassan's um essentially calling Ela a valid military target.
I guess Destiny, who's a total dumbass, who again, we had a like
a flawless victory here and this dumbass went there and made
him gave Hassan the ability to crime.
This this optical poison
loser came and ruined our Desi's like, "Guys, I'll go hard for
you." And they're like, "Please don't. Please distance yourself
from us and our children, okay? Listen, when it was just kind
of associating with you through Dan, it was one thing, but now
you're like kind of coming around us and our kids, and they've
had enough with the CPS thing, okay? Please leave. Please go
away. Aren't you Are you even allowed to be around kids? Can
you go? Can you get away? Can you get lost? Thank you. >> And
be the victim, which he did now. >> Oh,
like, oh my god, I'm getting >> Why? I don't understand
how people allow I don't understand how people allow Trump does
this. Hassan does this. These people will always reframe themselves
as the victim. Why take the bait? I don't understand why people
take the bait so hard on this. Like Hassan will always look for
anything that he can in order to try to blame somebody else or
divert to something else or talk about something bad empanada
says or whatever else. Um you shouldn't be so afraid to just
stand on whatever [__] you say. It's it's so insane
to me how spineless every online content creator is. is the >> I
don't think I don't think it's spineless. I don't think it's
spineless. I don't I don't think it's spineless at
>> Which he did now. He's been on his Instagram story being
like, "Oh my god, I'm getting >> Why? I don't understand
how people allow I don't understand how people allow Trump does
this. Hassan does this. These Dan left Destiny for Ethan." I
think so. The funny thing is is like Destiny is not the one getting
socially isolated by like he's not getting socially he he his
theory because obviously Connor is not you know a complex enough
creature to come up with this on his own. Connor was saying how
oh their goal is to like socially isolate Destiny. Destiny socially
isolates himself. Okay. You think do you think Queman or do you
think I or do you think like anyone Auggie anybody else do you
think we're powerful enough to make somebody stop a content creator
stop associating with like a a 5 to 10k average viewer streamer
who is known for like for like sending his audience like his
audience being militantly militant and following anyone who supports
him. There's just free money there. Destiny is isolating himself
despite being like free money for anyone who's willing to stomach
him. like free careers for anybody who's willing to stomach him.
Food shops running at like 300 400 average concurrence on YouTube
right now just for being able to stomach Destiny. That's all
right. There's no talent. There's no analysis. There is nothing
there. It's just on their tolerance of destiny and and his current
um actions
right? And somehow
it's like Mir Quimman laughing at this loser that's that's making
his friends run away. It's not him, you know, totally, willfully,
negligently messaging a minor minor, sorry, minor. It's not him
trying to uh traffic that minor across multiple states to to
get her to come see him for. It's not about uh doxing a bunch
of people. It's not about, you know, I think it could be reasonably
assumed he's connected to the doxes of some of the people that
were fighting with him a couple weeks ago, right? Like there's
it's not none of these actions. It's just it's just like uh it's
the snark community. Okay. It's it's it's the Destiny Stark community.
Play food shops spuring aidate style moment. No. What are you
doing? No, I'm not doing that right now. Uh do not say names
of people you think I could be referring to.
You will be timed out. You will be timed out. You will be timed
out. If you try to say names, you're a idiot. You're a [__]
idiot. You're a [__] idiot. Okay.
Chud was a food shops fan. No, that was not the case. That was
not the case. People will always reframe themselves as the victim.
Why take the bait? I don't understand why people take the bait
so hard on this. Like Hassan will always look for anything that
he can in order to try to blame somebody else or divert to something
else. Or guys, I know I solicited seam from that girl, but if
you thought about what Solo did, guys, I know that I solicited
Sean from that girl, but if you thought about like this solo
guy must be really bad. Could you guys all go check out that
that solo guy? Stop talking about me. Stop it. Didn't you know
that my revenge was leaked? Or talk about something bad empanata
says or whatever else. Um, you shouldn't be so afraid to just
stand on whatever [__] you say. It's It's so insane
to me how spineless every online content creator is. It's the
unilateral disarmament thing. >> Conor saying that Queen
normalized food shops today made me giggle. Yeah, he was like
totally on. Oh my god. You mean two days ago, right? Sorry. Yesterday,
right, dude?
Food Chops gets a five viewer bump from Queenman a logging her,
making fun of her. Okay, that's normalizing to Connor. All right.
Food Chops also retired because they could not maintain viewership,
right? And then they slowly built an audience off of just totally
riding ride or dying for Destiny, right? That's true, Queen.
But even if even if you gave her like a five or 10 viewer bump,
it was followed by her like falling off and retiring, right?
Destiny literally she resurrected her career by being a ride
or die for Destiny. She started a logging anybody who was an
OP of Destiny, right? And then Destiny started raiding her and
going on her stream. It's like if you How is that not normalizing
at 100 times the scale? Like can we just look at the at the difference?
Hold on. What is it? At food shops was taken social blade. Hold
on. Give me this. Give me this. Give me this. Approve. Like here's
where she gets Let's go to subscribers. Okay. So, it seems like
Okay. It seems like they were Huh. What what would have started
happening around here to like start exploding in subscribers,
do you think and views? What do we think would have happened
here? Wow. It seems like they were really successful when Queen
and A log them, guys. Let's go Max. Seems like they're very successful.
Very successful. Very successful. Entire history of their channel,
right? Gets up to here. They delete all of their videos
boom boom boom boom boom. They're they're already way over their
previous everything. Hose
food shops is a name even mean? I don't know. But apparently
Connor has a problem with people normalizing pedophilia or lollycon
consumer consumption. Apparently. Apparently. Hold on. You're
total.
No, you guys are total. Why would you Why would you be so stupid
as to take the bait on this? They're like trying to show that
you guys are unhinged towards our relevant. Why would you take
the bait? irrelevant. Immediately separated from Destiny immediately
called him out immediately. Can you guys use your brain cells
for two seconds? He's not a bad streamer. Use your brain cells
for two [__] seconds. And he's probably right about
those Twitter DMs. So, stop spurting out, okay?
Stop sporking out. Don't let somebody like manipulate you into
hating someone who's obviously on your side. Chill the out. All
right. Thank you. Thank you. It's all you got to do. It's all
you got to do. Okay. You're allowed to not like irrelevant too,
but like keep it reasonable. Just keep it reasonable. That's
all. Pointed out yesterday Connor is more concerned about lollycon
than actual cam. I'm telling you, dude. Oh my god. The other
thing I listened to on my way home today was that Perry stream.
Have you guys watched that Perry? Maybe. Hold on. What did I
want to do after this? Dude, I might just go play the Perry segment.
I might just play the Perry segment. I'm not joking. Connor is
a You guys are unaware Connor is something of a powder kick.
Okay, I probably shouldn't play it, but holy sh uh
dude, it was uh some crazy [__] What we can do is
we can go free Perry. Uh purple Perry. That's not purple Perry.
What the purple? Purple. No, purple. Oh, the other thing about
Perry's stream fun. He talked about Connor's son on the stream.
Talked about Connor's son. Anyone get a clip of that? Perry talking
about Connor's son. Anyone? Anyone get that clip?
>> Time is pretty dumb. >> I give up on this. >> I
like it when you react to two dry academics talking about this
topic. That's fine. Uh, the stream's probably not going to be
for you. Uh, Destiny/DG,
then let me do a big ass box. Let me do a big ass box and let's
do it. So, find out the smoke later. Does that please the grill
god? It sure does. Sure does. Nothing I do is going to help anyone.
Uh, so yeah, please, please, uh, for the sake of the world, wait
to be gang assemble. True. Uh, truth is the onion shadows make
a bit more sense now. Uh, yes and no. Uh, they're making more
sense than the evidence that they're working with. I don't think
that necessarily changes too much of the dynamic. Um, however,
I'm going to explain in depth why. And, uh, I'll do >> So,
what I I guess he's referring to the dynamic of honor uh, being
okay with what's working. >> You forgot to go over the
Lauren de Laguna stuff, I think. Okay. Where are the Lauren de
Laguna leaks? We'll read those as well. I I just don't I feel
like it was weird. It was just really weird these Lauren de Laguna
leaks. Hold on. Is this it? Yeah, it is. It's like Lauren de
Laguna just like messaged Destiny like a day ago or something.
I have no idea why. >> With Destiny, I'm guessing. Or does
he mean between Destiny and Rose momentarily, but there's a there's
a gentleman named Arion who's in our chat and he's like, "Dude,
Connor, this [__] is absolutely rubbing me the [__]
the wrong way. Why you sweing? Why you sweeping? Why you defending?"
Um, and I was kind of saying it's like, "I'm not sweeping. Sweeping
means I'm ignoring the problem. I'm not ignoring." >> No,
it doesn't. No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. Somebody tell Connor
that sweeping also means minimizing the problem. making the problem
smaller arbitrarily with no thought process, nothing to no thinking
towards what the problem could be, right? You just minimize it
as much as possible. That is also sweeping. >> I'm not
sweeping. I'm just going to keep working with Destiny and not
to ever bring it up to him ever. >> Oh, who am I kidding?
Con is going to bring this up to Destiny and allow him to sweep
for himself. >> I'm not minimizing. I'm trying to
scriptively. Now, maybe from an emotional degree, if I see people
being like, "So, he murdered his head and he's been knocked down
on a pike." Uh, if I say no, probably not that. Now only I'm
allowed to say that about food chops and Mr. Girl. People can't
say it about Destiny because he's going to save >> as minimizing.
And then uh I'm trying to think of what else. But truth be told,
I think I'm I'm a little tired, so I might get a little hazard,
a little probably >> It is minimizing. But it is minimizing
Connor. You know, you do like food trucks, so you minimize for
her. >> He's being transparent that he like minimizes.
He thinks Destiny's important, so he's not going to like care
about it as much. He was transparent about that with Vos, too,
right? That these weren't his principles. Like I don't I don't
know why he's trying to pull this back now. You were transparent
that you minimize your principles to accomplish goals. You are
a you're a means justifies the ends. Ends justifi. No, the ends
justify the means. Me
>> you it's like >> kind of guy. Okay. Kind of guy.
That's the kind of guy you are. You just don't care about your
your principles at all. You're flexible. Your spine has no it
has no integrity at all. Okay. Just bends with the wind. You're
wacky arm flailing inflatable tube man. Okay. You're all over
the place. >> Yeah. No, that's what Conor does. He minimizes
when it's people that he likes and he overexits and goes after
even people for not going hard enough. Like how he went over
charge for not going hard enough food shops when it's people
he doesn't like. Right? That is what you're doing. Why are you
saying that you're not just own it >> into the content?
>> I mean own it and then stop doing it cuz it's pathetic.
Whatever. >> That would be good for me to be tired and
have weirdness speaks and all that kind of stuff and for that
to get clipped and uh you know all that kind of stuff. So we'll
uh >> he's such a whiner too. He's such a little crybaby
whiner. No wonder he can put up with Destiny's whine. He's like,
"Oh, people are just clipping bad fates or whatever." It's such
a loser. Have >> fun seen anything yet. True. Keys. Do
you believe in rehabilitative justice for people who sack miners?
Uh, yeah, probably. Um, but >> that's great. That's great.
That's great. Good start. >> I mean, you know, rehabilitative
justice is what it is. But will Dusty ever face justice in the
first place? No. >> Bro, there's some really unique torture
going on here, okay? Where Perry has his mic eight times higher
than the audio of this video and he's the only person who watched
this apparently.
>> God damn it. This just a meme. >> Power presentation.
Power points. Nice, nice, nice, nice. We need to do that. Power
points. True. Confirm. New scandal. If not, it's the old one
or all lies. Not all eyes lies. Uh, misrepresentation, but uh
yeah, this this amount of stays representation. You know, you
know, you have crazy drama. >> Is corner points going to
pull out the versus heapilia versus epiblophilia definitions,
guys. >> Uh, take your bets in the comments down
>> Years later, you know that's crazy. No says liking the
stream. You should probably dislike the stream. As a matter of fact,
don't even like the stream, guys. Dislike it. Dislike the dislike
the stream preemptively. Conc guy. Hell yeah, guys. He's in a
fe. Come on. Exactly. Yeah, Steve Steven wasn't known targeting
underage like yeah we'll get into the narrative details but I
kind of >> it's
well he didn't he all this did was go on Twitter where people
don't have to age verify find somebody using the hashtag TNSW
which is known by him to include a lot of minor people not ask
for ID allegedly ask for ID actually and then they don't respond
continue engaging with them but not get ID and then just say
it's like you know he's not he doesn't know that they're 17 he's
just acting in a way that maximizes the opportunity for them
to be underage. >> I kind of want to show you guys like
a values like first principles things first. So maybe I'm going
to do an intro and kind of go over the drama uh real
>> I'm a broken conservative. So I'll do an intro and then
we'll do that. I'm just going to warn I guess from what I know
I was an old irrigation line in my backyard spent two hours digging
a two to three foot radius hole hole hole hole hole hole hole
that was 3 week pipe only to find it was a thin wall pipe and
the only thing the hardware store had was caps but caped two
hours to boot cure and then turn on the water to find out that
it was a loop system. Oh no. So we had to go back and get another
cap. So I had to cap both ends of the cup pipe and start our
hard store was closed. I slept on the floor because I was covered
in dirt with no shower to wash off the joys of home ownership.
Bro. Yeah. Leard and faces >> did you just post food in
my chat? Jacob, did you just post food in my chat? I might actually
ban food from general chat again just because you posted somebody's
food in my chat. Okay, why would you do this? Why the would I
care? Sorry, somebody just posted this sty tweet at Willy M show.
Sorry to interrupt your marital bliss with your brown wife, sir,
but are you aware that they got your man's assault charges? The
you be hanging with the you be hanging with boy? a defender and
he was your man's a
[__] deeper
Willie Mack on his honeymoon checking his phone to distract himself
from his brown wife screaming at a boat tour guide over a rental
feed price and seeing all this Deeperama you can get in on the
ground floor. Okay, this is the this guy's going to have 100,000
followers by the end of 2026 at minimum. Okay, at minimum 100,000
followers by the end of 2026.
It's coming. It's going to happen, right? It's It's going to
happen. Let's just read this guy's feed. Actually, you know what?
That's not a terrible idea.
Beloved followers, please stop. Please put a stop to my despicable
son's outrageous slander against me. You have my blessing.
God, it's so hard to avoid that topic right now. But we must
deeper. I'm getting now retweeting. First Destiny ruins my number
one favorite podcast of all time. Sugar and spice. And now he's
ending the number two. Anything else? I hate this guy.
dude, Deep Rama has to break character at this tweet where Destiny
reminds us that like he actually I actually just posted those
pictures of that minor to get Kiwi Farms to dox them. Like, dude,
I get it. Why? Uh, just principle. Soapbox society just feels
wrong. I'm I'm even breaking that principle. I'm bending it to
its breaking point, but can't go all the way. Okay. Can't go
all the way. God, dude. He really did it. He really just went
and did it on this one. I This is baffling stuff. Okay. It's
just baffling, dude. Conor's pretending he went to sleep. Connor's
pretending that he can't give me this string cuz he went to bed.
I don't believe him. I don't believe him at all. Wait, what?
What the [__] is this? What are you saying right
now? That is actually exactly what's happening, by the way. You
can hear it in the background. I don't know if you can hear [__]
in my background. Not joking. Anyway, [__] me. I'm
okay. Is there anything else we wanted to cover today or are
we done? Are we really done? There's no way we're done, right?
There's got to be other [__] Wait, what? His wife
called him a while listening to him.
There's no way that happened, bro. Come on, man. >> I just
don't ask why he gave the doctor school to dig. Yeah, it's pretty
dumb.
>> what what should turn on the water to find out that
it was a looped system. Oh, no. So, you had to go back and get
another cap. So, I had to cap both ends of the cup pipe and had
them and start harbor was closed. So, I slept on the floor because
I covered in dirt with no shower to wash off. Kill me. The joys
of home ownership, bro.
>> I don't grasp why the dumbass gave the doctors her school
to dig. And what does Connor say to this? >> Yeah. Leard
and Face says, "I just don't grasp why he gave the doctors her
school to dig." Yeah, it's pretty dumb. Pretty. >> I was
just a little guy accidentally. Whoopsie. Whoopsy daisy. >> I'm
going to try to keep it I'm going to try to keep it on like >> Wait,
what was the thing where Destiny said like uh actually we can
do anything to these people? Was it Was it doxing? Was it playing
footsies with kiwi farms? So over for you. Once Destiny clears
up his name in the crime lawsuit, gets off the police report,
and finally finds the evidence that proves she's 18. He's over
30, by the way. Then he will be so big and American liberals
win. Yep. >> The morals and principles and virtue and all
that kind of stuff. And >> I'm I'm on borrowed time right
now. >> I'll try to keep the virtues and vices and I'll
try to >> It's because Destiny likes exposing PII about
people cuz he gets off on making people's lives worse. >> The
nitty-gritty criticisms of detail. I'll leave that for other
people. Shine says there's no shot there. This book of fire someone
big is isn't going to drop eventually. Um, maybe. But I do think
that like >> Oh, we get those Lauren logs. Just looking
for my Dan. Where are my Dan logs at? Here we go. Someone big's
going to drop eventually. Well, speak of the devil. Look at that.
Would you look at that? Would you look at that? You finally treating
Perry with respect. I've always treated Perry with respect. What
are you talking about? I just thought it was really funny how
he described counterpoints today. Okay, that's all. This is very,
very, very interesting. All right. Powder keg. Powder keg. A
powder keg. way though, right? Unless unless he's done substantially
more. You obviously if he's actually a serial killer or or an
assaulter, then then yeah, that obviously take him out because
incarceration. But as far as I know, that's not the >> No,
he's only, you know, >> who's this guy in Connor's chat?
I don't I don't recognize this guy at all. Who's this guy? Who's
that? [__] that guy? >> That's crazy. Chad
>> committing statutory something. What would the law be?
Someone sent me the law. So this would violates what Destiny
is doing. Whatever. Whatever >> accusations. So anyways,
you mean the 3 years a came out now, my bro? What is that argument?
Um, I'm saying that it happened in 22. That's what I'm saying.
So, that's what I'm saying with within the uh within the time.
>> Guys, I know we just found about found out about it
recently, but it happened in 2022. She's like an adult now. Okay,
guys. Rose is an adult now. Why are you freaking out? Why are
you pretending something bad happened here? She's over 18 now.
>> The time uh says, >> "Dad's watching this Lucer
Connor stream and they should be watching nature documentaries.
It's [__] up, you know. It's going to It's really
[__] up. You know you're going to >> All the
poor children get neglected for the wrong reasons. >> Hey
Confederations of Yos Call him Arsler and nothing else for trying
to fly out a child who feels like crushingly. Well, we we'll
break it down. We'll break it down. We'll break >> How?
Oh, thank you boost gold water for the push prime. Very appreciated.
Very >> And epic. >> Uh yeah. So, so actually let
me let me do an intro. Let me do >> I was I thought that
Connor was playing Call the Doctor. I was going to I was like,
let's go. No, but thank you. But thank you. It was a cool >> overview.
And then let me uh let me do a intro, an overview, and then we're
going to start drawing virtues, spices, relationships, all that
kind of stuff. So, anyways, let's give it a crack. So, hi guys.
My name is Conser
Republican and we are cover. >> That's way too fast. What
the [__] is Perry doing? >> You think that
one day Connor will re realize that like just cuz he's pretending
to be a nerd doesn't mean >> I have to I have to hear his
breakdown on how actually that minor is not that bad from a conservative
point of view. Okay. Although maybe I shouldn't be shocked. I
guess this is like the he's employing the Roy Murk. Okay. >> We
believe him >> drama today. If you want something more
dry, more substantive, more politicky, you're probably just going
to come back later. Uh there's a large round that's unfolding
in the Twitch YouTube political space. Uh and it affects people
that are close to me, I guess. And so we kind of just need to
address it head on, go over the nitty-gritty details, fight with
people in chat, etc., etc. Uh just so we're not sweeping because
uh sweeping sweeping for those of you who misuse the term sweeping,
sweeping problem under the r. I'm not trying to sweep the problem
under the rug. I'm trying to stare at the problem. I'm trying
to describe accurately my >> Yeah, I guess you're just
um enabling it. Yeah, I guess enabler would be a better term
than corner. That's true. Enabler. You're an enabler. You're
a sweeper. You're an enabler. >> I'm trying to describe
accurately other people's positions. I'm trying to describe accurately
an enabler. So expect heavy chat interaction in lots of Microsoft
Paint drawings today. With all that being said, let me do a summary
from my perspective. So, Twitch YouTube politics has been dominated
by three personalities for the past decade almost. So, Stephen,
>> is he gonna guys, okay, I could do a I could do a bingo
sheet. I could do a bingo sheets. The only issue is I'm kind
of running out of time cuz like I said, guy, my my stream schedule's
I don't even know I'm going to be able to watch this. Let me
do a bingo sheets. That's what I'm going to do. Okay. Um
cuz I can't cover it. Let's see. Well, >> I don't I don't
know what this is. Is the cool Warhammer music. Wait, did he
did he just do he just did bingo and then he ended? God damn
it. Was it back for like a minute after the bingo sheet? Okay,
dude. I'm just expecting somebody to reach out and be like, I
got it. I got the archive.
There's nobody. >> Apparently, this is the cool Warhammer
music. What a what a what a what a still what a still image.
What a great still image, guys. >> Better chance of becoming
president. Destiny or Fentesto?
This is why it's um what do you call it? It's not always good
ideas to stream end of like a 20our day. Wait, you got it, Shimu?
You got it. Or are you saying you got the food shops one? You're
going to go file it. Look like I missed the Connor one. Wait,
why was the food shops one deleted? I think Connor will give
me a version of this, by the way. Uh, yuga class. I don't know.
I don't know if that's necessarily the case. Got privated when
I checked before going live. Not sure why. Okay. All right. That's
Shimuja said that. Hey, this follower says Connor would be more
likely to give you a VOD if you don't say he's pretending to
sleep. Connor will give the vod because he foolishly thinks that
he actually has good ideas and he's like, "Oh, I can totally
stand up to scrutiny." It's because Connor is too understand
how he is. That's why he'll give me the VOD. Okay, you can act
like he would get offended by this, but he won't go, "No, I'm
I can totally stand up on my two own two feet in the uh marketplace
of ideas, but he's basically Helen Keller in that in that venue."
Okay, continue. >> The second started streaming in 2010.
Uh he was a Starcraft streamer and a video game streamer for
the first six years of his life. He transitioned into debates
in 2016. Um, in 2016 he debated a lot of people that I would
consider I was fans of at the time that include people like Sargon,
Dave Rubin. Um, now he didn't debate people like Shuahhead and
Chris, but he obviously talks smack about those kinds of characters.
Um, and so I was vaguely aware of Destiny's existence in 1618,
but truth be told I was an antJW uh, sphere at that time. That's
kind of like my natural point of politics is like mild rightwing
reactionary against the leftwing. That's kind of my natural my
natural position. But anyways, uh, the point is that uh, effectively
through 2020 through 2020, oh, excuse me. Um, I got done being
a cop in 2019.
So I started YouTube in 2019, 2020. Um, but I was throwing all
sorts of content at the wall. I was live streaming. I was doing
panel debate shows. I was doing 20-minute political rants. I
was doing Warhammer breakdown content. I was doing movie breakdown
content. And that's
that was good because it gave me
but I still Yeah. My my my my attempts my AI tap to people's
work. Yeah. It's actually doing really it's really good. You
know, it's a really study um why he looked like that. Um he doesn't
have a soul frugal. He doesn't have a soul. He abus his wife.
He abuses kids. That's what happens with >> You didn't
miss anything, Stasia. You didn't miss anything. I'm uh I'm tapped.
I'm making this room go longer than it should. Let me see here.
Let me take a look. I could I could try to do the merk stuff.
I just feel like I'm not. Ah, Tom Foolery. What is there? What
is there for Tom? We had TomTent yesterday. Is there more Tom
10 tonight? So much to cover. Someone's got this Connor stream.
Some streamer reacted to this Connor stream before it went down,
right? Somebody
There's like a three viewer streamer out there who watched this
Connor stream. I swear to God. Or does he? Wait, he There's no
way he does he not duo stream. Would he do a stream to Twitch?
Is there any way I got three streams from him on stream recorder?
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
No. No. He didn't go he didn't go live on Twitch for this. Oh,
he went live on Twitch a couple days ago, but he didn't live up
on Twitch for this. Me? Really? He went live like two days ago
to cover Live and Learn Civil War. Bro, come on, man. It's not
on Valor Media Network. Perry's Perry's stream ends in 2 seconds.
It's my white whale right now. Okay, call Perry. I don't think
Perry's online. Wait, is it this? No, I doubt it. Maximus, if
you I kind of doubt it. Hold on. Maybe that is it. One second.
>> And uh we we Nope. Nope. This is not it. This We already
watched this. This is a day ago. Looking for one from today.
What are we looking for? The the counterpoint stream from today,
Stasia. That's what we're looking for. You try DMing him? I did.
I did DM him. We'll see the answers. No, I don't think he streams
anywhere else. In the meantime, in the meantime, >> I'm
I've done two years of psychology. I can mind read people. Oh,
we did this with you. >> I know what's going on. I bet
you everyone has autism because I'm going to diagnose everyone
because I took one abnormal cycle. >> Yeah, we have the
link and it's uh nuked by copyright. I have it, but I'm not going
to share it because nobody asked me how my day was. Listen, some
people have been talking me in the internet. So, I'm going to
let this uh this child trafficker go, okay? I'm not going to
help anyone cuz people have been talking me on the internet,
but at least it was entertainment for Discord people. Okay. Oh,
we had the Lauren de Laguna thing. Check that out. We'll read
that real quick. And then I think um I think I'm piecing out
after Lauren de the Lauren de Lagona thing. All right, I'll take
I'll take a quick look. See what we got for content elsewhere.
But this might be it. This might be it. So, last message from
Lauren de Laguna to Destiny was July 16th, 2023 at 4:05 a.m.
this morning or yesterday morning. I'm not sure yet. Haha. Have
the day you deserve. Don't dead. Don't reaffend is what she sent
him. Jesus Christ. making VPN to go around copyright um on Disney
stuff. I don't know, man. Maybe go to China. Should we try China?
Thanks, babe. Always as always, or sorry, thanks babe always
is what Destiny responds. She sends this the logs. You're mean
to me for no reason. I stopped speaking to you because I found
out about the group chats you were sharing our private messages
on that you swore to never share. You try to convince Really
and Jasmine to stop being my friend. Then you pretend I'm involved
in Pixie's lawsuit when you know I am not involved at all and
encouraged her not to file. If you treated people with kindness,
this wouldn't have happened. That's what you did to me. What
you did to Pixie was
What you did to the minor you tried to seduce is unspeakable.
I pray for you
Not good. Not good. Not good. Not good. Not good. Not good. Not
good. All right, Ozel. All right, chill. I can't wrap my head
around it because I know I was always so kind to you and Pixie
is nice to everyone. She didn't deserve this. And Destiny responds,
"What's it like living with schizophrenia? Is that is that like
an everyday thing for you or does it come and go in waves?"
I wouldn't know, but it sounds horrific and I would try to empathize
with someone like that instead of kicking them when they're down
like you did to Zena. She's diagnosed schizophrenic and you laughed
about her struggling despite her grandma dying due to due to
use of the same medications she would need to take to get better.
You have no empathy or sympathy in your heart for people for
even for people who love you. I loved you. Pixie loved you. Zena
had a deep feeling of friendship for you. Your family loves you.
Molina loved you. You treated all of them with unbearable hostility
and hate. That's really weird that you loved me when we weren't
even dating. Why do you keep lying about that? Lol. Because you're
lying about that. You perused me. You perused me. Pursued me,
I assume. Hard for months, then dirty deleted all the messages.
Then I stopped speaking to you because you're toxic and mean
to me. You started with love bombing, then became a dick. I think
you hate yourself so much you hate people who love you. When
do you think we actually dated? Lol. Starting with the trip through
California, we went out many times and stayed in uh many nights
after then for about 9 months. Then I found out all the you were
doing and I told you I didn't want to speak to you anymore. So
I was dating you while I was married at the same time. Lol.
Yes, you told me Molina was blaming blaming me for the end of
your relationship with her, which I think in hindsight was another
lie. You lied about Molina to make me hate her. This is a schizophrenia
manifest. Wow, dude. I I don't know why. Like, obviously he would
leak these things. I don't know why
Lauren would do this to be honest. Why she would message um obviously
Destiny's going to leak this. Obviously going to have pretend
it proves some point. Seems like a massive mistake, but okay.
Uh which sucks because that risked our friendship. I guess hers
and Molina's friendship.
Also, how do you fail as a public defender? Lau.
Apparently, maybe Lauren's no longer a public defender. I don't
know. I liked her more than you. Always have. I didn't fail.
I learned what I needed to and left. But even if I had, even
if I was the biggest failure in the world, you were supposed
to be a master debater. Why are you deflecting? You lied about
Molina. You lied about Farah. Then you tried to lie about me
to Jasmine. Thank God that woman has the moral compass has a
moral compass. The moral compass, sorry, made of stone. Because
my as my friend, she immediately went to call me out for the
bad behavior you made up that I did. And I proved you lied. You're
a liar. I don't lie about any of these people. That's why whenever
anyone pushed me for evidence for anything, I was able to prove
it. You've drifted through so many friend groups because of how
much of an insane snake you are. Lol. Uh he had evidence for
like private conversations because he records private conversations
without informing the other person, right? Consistently to try
to win conversations later. The polyamory guy pretending to it's
impossible for them to be dating while he's married. Well, the
open relationship guy, which still makes it possible to date
other people, I think,
right? Uh he's somewhere between open and and Paulie. I guess
he he kind of used from what I understand he used Molina as kind
of a totem where like he didn't really love Molina or care about
her but Molina was like the plausible he not plausible it was
like um Molina was his his reason to not be able to get romantically
involved with other people right so he's like oh I can only have
because Molina right that's like that's what Molina was for him
like the the way to to not have to engage like emotionally with
anybody else or he could turn that off whenever he Lena specifically
didn't want him to have any other girlfriends. Yeah, but I think
their relationship was basically on the rocks totally at this
point anyway, right? I'm not mistaken. Was she in Sweden at this
point already? I can't remember. I feel like she might have already
gone to Sweden. Anyway, continuing. Lying about Martin, lying
about that doctor that you lying about me, etc., etc. Nice memes.
I didn't lie about any of them and Martin and I still talk and
the doctor went to jail because other women accused him, not
me. You lied about all of them and your proof is often missing
context if you deleted important parts of messages. You lie through
obsolete. I don't know what that. Okay. You lied about me to
Jasmine. How come everyone now that the courts are involved are
able to show what really happened? Here's a specific lie. You
lied about me representing Pixie or asking for $50 million or
creating any Kiwi Farms accounts. Kiwi Farms or Reddit accounts.
Can you explain that? Where's your proof? Never said you were
representing Pixie. Um, you said she was getting legal advice,
right? I'm I'm pretty sure Destiny said Pixie was getting legal
advice from Lauren and that it was a massive conflict of interest.
I'm pretty confident that was said, but maybe not. Maybe that's
maybe the wording there is a little different. But I know you
two are actively talking about the case in the background. And
Pixie demanded 15 million, not you. Lol. And I'm pretty sure
you made the KF account, but that it's obvious. It's hard to
prove. Obviously, I didn't. Are you 31 now? Do you wonder why
you have no permanent friends, no boyfriend, husband, no kids?
Do you think that's going to change anytime soon? Um, does Destiny
wonder why he had all of these things and lost them? Do you think
there's any reflection going on there from the other side that
like he he didn't just not have them, he had them and lost all
of them? Do you think there's any reflection that happens? Think
there's anything that makes him look inside and go, "Oh, I pushed
all of those things away." I'm mocking her for the things that
I willingly destroyed. Wasn't he saying he's trying to get Lauren
disbarred? He was indeed. He had a wife. He had permanent friends.
He had kids.
He's pushed all of those things away and out of his life. People
keep saying Desty kept the plug in the divorce. No, Molina,
I've done more with this than you ever have. You cannot have
it. You cannot have it, Molina. Pixie, Amy, Virginia, Jazz, this
is I I just This is a rough conversation when when far when Sorry,
not far. But um Lauren is like, "Actually, I do have friends.
Who are my friends? Don't do that." When you're arguing with
somebody like this, don't do that. Okay, that's not not a good
look. Pixie, Amy, Virginia, Jasmine, Kyla. Friends, you don't
know in California and Arizona and from the military. I'm dating
someone. This is still deflection. Now, hold on. You don't know
what Kyla that is. You don't know what Kylo that is. You do not
know. Okay. You do not know. I'm just telling you. All right.
You don't know. Uh, can you exp. So, hold on. Wait. Did we just
get a duplicate here? We did. Oh, we're nearly at the end. She
just mean This is still deflection. She just mean. Okay. Uhhuh.
Uh-huh. I'm sure. Just like you were dating me. I'm not being
mean to you. I'm pointing out that you hurt me and lied. Okay,
Stephen, keep lying. It's all you have. Salute. Yeah. Wasn't
she defending NYSE earlier today? Maybe saying that she didn't
know. Um,
Kyla didn't want to know. I I'll tell you whatever Kyla didn't
know, she didn't want to know. That's how she operated. Okay.
All I I've said this multiple times, right? I'm going to have
posted the DMs. First thing I told Kyla was, "You better ask
Destiny what he did exactly." And to be honest with you, because
at the end of this, like you need to know when he's lying. Like
when once he once proof comes out and you know he's lying, you
need to be able to to get away, right? Defense squad Collins
versus a handicap Jtock would go hard. I don't think any of those
people are around and I'm not really that worried about it right
now. I doubt any of those people are around anyway.
I don't know. She really should have also talked to any everyone
on the other side. She only spoke to Pixie. Yeah, you'd think
so. Destiny crashing out posting edgy memes from Instagram. H.
All right.
All right. I don't know what else we got here, guys. I'm looking
for that Connor stream for tomorrow. I'm looking for I'm actually
not sure. I We might just do the kick stuff tomorrow, to be honest
with you. Shut up, Kathy. I'm not doing Collins. Shut up. No,
Slime. No, we're not doing that. Clean with the queue is Kathy.
Yes, it's obviously Kathy. It's obviously always been Kathy.
Remember when Lauren would go on panels streaming from some crazy
mansion randomly? Yeah, there's like her family's estate in Mexico
or something. Okay. Can we watch an animal video first? Sure.
Link an animal video. Then I'm out of here. What you eating?
The curry chicken I was eating last night. Maximus said he had
one. Says he has one. You going to link it, Maximus? Maybe. Maybe
we watch. Finish the Fentes clip. No. Hey, Maximus and Creger
are both linking. Give me a second. Maximus. We got Creger. These
guys.
They just push each other. Are these both the same thing? Did
you guys both link the same thing at the same time? There's no
way you just There's no way you both linked this at the same
time. That's wild. You guys both independently linked the Koala
video. >> These guys aren't that funny. I read I saw a
sign.
>> Uh Riy, no, I don't think you missed anything. There's
like the Dan Sorry, you're going to have a rough time with this
VOD. There's like the Dan stuff. There's the I just read the
Lauren Deon logs. Okay. >> They just they just push each
other until one gives up. Do they look how flow he's attacking?
>> It's a weird sound.
>> This is the most boring boring fight I've ever seen.
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god.
Oh god. Goodness. Goodness.
Goodness. Goodness. >> What the [__] is this
satanic sound?
>> The [__] What is this? I don't know what
the [__] this is. Why are you linking me 13-year-old
YouTube videos? Some blackface weirdo. Spruce Willis, get your
together. Okay, get your [__] together. Credit to
Trucker Joe. We love Trucker Joe. Okay, honestly guys, I hope
you appreciate that I even went live tonight. Okay, I have exhausted.
I will be back probably tomorrow. Wait, definitely tomorrow.
100% tomorrow. I'll be back with energy and a docket and all
of the things. Okay, all of the things I'm going to write out.
See we got here. We got Resi. We got LTG. We got Amaranth. We
got Nick.
What? Hold on. No. No. No. No. No. We We're not leaving. Hold
on. What? Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Hold on. No. No. No. No. No.
Come on. Shimu just posted Shimu, are you here still? Shimu,
are you here still? Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Shimu, are you
here still? What's the thing you just posted? Is that like mocking
somebody who said something or
are you just mocking somebody who said something or is that real?
Did that actually happen? Is that like confirmed in some way?
I I actually have no idea. I've not tapped into that, but I'm
just like that's crazy if that happened. Okay. Okay. Yeah, that's
what I figured. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's what I figured. No,
I figured I figured based on context you're posting somebody
lying about it. Okay. Okay. All right. Dude, at this rate, he's
just spitefully hanging on so that he can be here after Destiny
finishes himself off. Okay. He's just waiting around. He knows
it's coming. He knows that the walls are closing in. All right.
He's got to outlive He's got to outlive one guy. Got to outlive
one guy and he's going to make it happen. All right. Raid resi.
All right. I'll raid resi. There's resi. Okay. Have a good night,
guys. I'll be back. Bye-bye. Good